David how likely is it that Donald Trump
will declare martial law at some point
in his presidency either to avoid being
impeached and removed or if he loses in
2020 to avoid relinquishing the White
House or in advance of the 2020 election
to justify not having the election
altogether all right so three different
scenarios where the this emailer wonders
if Donald Trump will apply martial law
declare martial law here's the reality
it's extremely unlikely it is extremely
so martial law is a suspension
effectively of the normal
law-enforcement infrastructure of the
country replaced by the military taking
control of domestic law enforcement now
on a federal level only the president
has the power to impose martial law and
this all goes back to limitations on
martial law that exists thanks to Court
decisions which were established between
the Civil War and World War two so for
example in 1878 Congress passed the
Posse Comitatus Act which forbids
military involvement in domestic law
enforcement without congressional
approval and that ultimately may be what
is the deciding factor here even if we
attribute absolutely the worst
intentions to donald trump which include
that in an act of desperation where he's
about to get convicted on impeachment or
he's about to lose the election or he
has lost the election and it's almost
time for him to go the idea is in an act
of desperation he will declare martial
law strictly speaking you need
congressional approval in order to
declare martial law based on the Posse
Comitatus Act so I think the better
question is would Trump try to put in
place martial law maybe although I still
doubt it but if he did who's in control
of the House and Senate at the time and
would they allow it and this is why once
again you know we talked about the 2018
midterms and Democrats taking over
control of the house now they have the
investigative power of the house now we
have impeachment hearings now we are
potentially heading
the direction of a trial of an
impeachment trial this is why this stuff
matters and this is why taking over the
Senate and although it's an uphill
battle in 2020 or maybe in 2022 that's
why this stuff really matters I believe
that there is no question Donald Trump
will make the case that because of some
unfair treatment either in the context
of the impeachment inquiry or the
election or whatever Trump will make the
case that he didn't really lose or that
someone cheated or that this was rigged
or this that that was rigged her the
other thing I think it is less likely
that he will actually try to declare
martial law and I think it is almost an
impossibility that he would be able to
get away with it
but things have happened for the first
time before I mean think about other
times martial law has been declared in
the United States is very limited I
think after Pearl Harbor was bombed
martial law was declared and if I have
my history correct I almost don't want
to say but I think that that was related
to the internment camps of Japanese
Americans but the instances in which
martial law was was declared are
extraordinarily limited and the idea
that a House and Senate would allow
particularly when not controlled by
Trump's party that the House and Senate
would allow Trump to declare martial law
because he thinks the election against
him was unfair that the election that
went against him was unfair seems
extremely unlikely but I'm willing to
have my mind changed